this blocky building wasn't really
constructed here it was actually made in
a factory and then it was shipped
hundreds of miles and assembled on site
I wanted to see how you could construct
a modular building like this one in a
factory so I came to one this is known
as modular
construction and it could be a big deal
for the US's construction industry which
has been facing a worker shortage for
years amid a national crisis for
affordable housing experts say modular
builds can reduce costs by 20% and
timelines by up to 50 but the industry
faces some serious logistical challenges
as production ramps up across the US two
of its largest startups have already
failed so is modular construction meant
to last so everything in this Factory
essentially starts out like this block
of wood right yeah absolutely so the
project that we're looking at here is
going to become an extended state Hotel
in Philadelphia this Factory is owned by
by volumetric building companies or vbc
a construction company that's built some
of the largest modular buildings in the
country the factory stretches nearly a/4
mile long and is divided into stations
here workers build units one at a time
that will later fit together to make an
entire building to build one of these
modular units it all starts with the
flooring next they put the walls up
they'll put in drywall and electrical
and then lastly they'll add the
finishing touches as they come together
they make their way down the factory by
connecting rail line kind of like a
massive conveyor belt and things here
move fast things are actually happening
so fast in this Factory that I'm
struggling to keep up we can have a
module from one end of the line to the
other in about a week so this should
measure out to be about 12 1/2 ft wide
and 65 ft long just small enough to fit
on a tractor trailer that gets chipped
to its
destination on site workers combine the
units install utilities and add
finishing touches so it looks like any
other building inside we actually design
all of our modules to be structurally
independent to transport via Road for
long distances and to be lifted by a
crane that structural requirement ends
up making our components stronger than
the individual Parts would be on a sight
built project why would someone choose
modular construction over traditional
construction the primary reasons are
driven by schedule certainty and cost in
traditional construction workers might
have to wait until the building's
Foundation is set to start assembling
walls and other components but with
modular construction workers can be
building the foundation on site and the
modules in the factory at the same time
speeding up the entire process this
project was finished in 22 months about
half of what the construction schedule
would have been should it have been
built on site and the faster companies
can complete their buildings the quicker
they can start charging occupants
modular companies can also buy raw
materials in bulk which can be an
advantage over traditional construction
when you understand the modules that
you're building you can actually order
material to the size and specifications
that you need where in traditional
construction you're still having to
construct and measure that out on a job
site to make it fit so it's it's just
much more efficient in modular
construction and since these buildings
are made in factories using similar
step-by-step processes modular
construction needs fewer skilled workers
than traditional construction that comes
at a critical time since the constru
construction industry still struggles
from a worker shortage even as the
number of construction jobs Rose in 2023
we don't have a lot of people going into
the trade the way that we did in the 50s
the 60s and the 70s you can train people
much faster and modular construction
because they're working on a short set
of rope tasks as we lose our skilled
Workforce over the next decade modular
will become more utilized in almost
every environment but experts say that
modular construction works best for
buildings with repeatable units like
hospitals schools multif family units
and hotels and a 20203 McKenzie report
found that the modular construction
industry isn't growing as fast as
expected why do you think it's been so
hard to gain acceptance here I think
that there's plenty of reasons why
modular has struggled in the US not
every city in the country needs modular
to build housing efficiently there are
times where modular construction can be
more expensive than traditional
construction that's especially in
locations where labor isent full or low
cost or where the factory is located a
very long distance away some of the
downfalls that we're still struggling
with is the impact of having to
transport these modules to job sites it
costs a lot of money to lift and pick
those modules into a building and so
sometimes we get height restrictions
that make it tough vbc is one of many
companies fighting to get a foothold in
the US market but in the past 2 years
two other major modular companies V Kara
have gone bankrupt does this make you
worry at all about the future of modular
Construction in the US I think everybody
should be worried about the future of
construction both in the US and globally
modular building is probably not going
to save the construction industry but I
do believe that we are a huge part of
the future the first guys through the
wall often get bloodied in some ways
we're all learning and progressing
because of the things that catara and
skender and be have done we've produced
6,000 units over the last decade which
is substantially more than almost any
other company in this space startup or
otherwise I think what we have to really
focus on for modular construction for it
to make the next wave is to use it for
the asset types that it's really suited
for if we can find locations where we
can build these modular systems that are
close to the site there's some
advantages if you will then that really
make it much more advantageous than
traditional
Construction